well we have lucked out not only is it
national egg salad week but today is
also national cold brew day and here to
help us celebrate both is bronwyn
decorah from founders coffee welcome
thank you so much what a beautiful setup
here now founders coffee is famous for
their coffee but your food your food is
spectacular and you're going to show us
a little sample of what you have to
offer and help us celebrate national egg
salad week with your famous egg salad
yes show us how it is done over at yes
so it's really basic just a few
ingredients sometimes the simplicity of
it is what makes it so good it's great
and if you mess it up you just add a
little bit extra of something if you're
not sure so chopped boiled egg we do a
house-made garlic aioli sweet pickled
relish chives salt pepper that's easy
that's it mix it all together i know
absolutely so if you wanted to dump that
eggs right in there the eggs yep and
then
how much i mean is this is just for
garnish we don't like put that one
a little bit
i mean
if we want to kiss someone after we
don't want too much money yeah
garlic aioli and chives you know what
are you going to do a little bit of
relish a lot a little bit what do you
like
let's do that and then some mayonnaise
so this is a garlic aioli oh it's an
aioli that's a little different it's a
little different it's got that garlic so
you're not kissing anybody we're not
kissing anybody that's probably good and
then some salt and pepper absolutely
i'll slide it over for you okay can we
do it just a little fancy oh nice is
that good that's good all right give it
a mix girl mix
and then the finished product we have
over here on
so we do two dishes we do an egg salad
toast with a multigrain bread and then
we have an egg salad croissant and then
there's
secret menu things that you can do if
you wanted egg salad on an everything
bagel you can do that you can customize
the toppings my personal favorite is
chopped bacon on my egg salad toast
because that's delicious and look at
that i mean look at this is what it
looks like after this is this is the
before
this is the after yeah this is what it
is it's supposed to look like that is
gorgeous i mean your food is absolutely
thank you so much and there's some of
the other offerings that you have here
too i did bring a few we have avocado
toast and blueberries and cream toast
our avocado toast again with a
house-made garlic aioli and a whole
avocado yum it's delicious let's talk
about the cold brew since it is national
cold brew day we have here so cold brew
is
coffee
cold it's cold coffee so the difference
with cold brew and regular coffee is
you're not using hot water when you make
cold brew and that results in less
acidity so if you're the kind of person
that gets a little bit of a tummy ache
after drinking coffee
this actually has low acidities
a little bit more mild it's much
smoother but it's also a little bit
heavier than regular coffee so basically
coffee ground espresso cold water and
you let it steep at room temperature for
8 to 24 hours depending on how strong
you like it and then and then you strain
it off pour it over ice and you can top
it with a little bit of cream if you
like you can add flavors vanilla right
now our cold brew is in our coffee
flight you want some all of the time
yeah absolutely let's let's cheers this
to national cold brew day right i mean
look at that is there more caffeine in
cold brew
yes and no no it depends on how long you
steep it do you want any cream for sure
okay to national cold brew day where can
people come visit you so we have two
locations okay we are on
durango and sunset over by ikea and we
have another location in henderson on
saint rose parkway right across the
street from costco you'll find us at
founderscoffeeco.com
all the caffeine you need and some
delicious food too cheers to national
cold brew day there's more lots